yeah enjoy the ride these stupidest idea  I've ever heard of in my life I forgot  that you were the only one to bring the  plane down no no only thing I've ever  seen him take down was uh no knees  Denise remember their prom really bright  yet you're gonna do that right here so  you're trying to get me off my point  it's not the same when there's no future  are you talking about you got nothing  but future I mean a future together  growing old together without that love  is it's just heartbreak for they need to  take extreme measures  I am and I am voting on play-action  anybody remember when I carried a new  through a wormhole no never come save  New York never heard that recall that  hostile alien army came charging through  a hole in space we're staying the 300  feet below it worthy Avengers we can  bust arms dealers all the live long day  but that up there that's that's the  endgame how are you guys planning on  beating that